some of the same mindset challenges i
had when i was launching my business in
i hit those same mindset challenges in
when the secret had come out when i was
on oprah then i hit the same mindset
challenges and needed the same mindset
shifts in 2018
when my company was five times larger
so i see this on my campus so often
people often assume
that they need to get another coach to
speak more powerfully well in some cases
that might be the case they need to join
another community
that might be the case in some cases or
learn another
skill set a new skill set
well actually sometimes
it's
a mindset shift
they need to make a needlepoint move in
their thinking
working on their mindset you can stay in
the same community you can have the same
coach
you can do the same things but with a
different mindset it produces a
different outcome have you stopped to
think about the fact that everything we
do everything we physically do starts
first in our mind the opportunity to
examine your mind and steering how you
decide the direction that you want to go
in or not like that's something that
that we don't spend enough time thinking
about that we should actually go hold on
let me talk about let me think about my
mindset need motivation what's your top
10 with the live nation hey it's evan
carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best lisa nichols and my take on
her top 10 was a success enjoy
rule number two customize your message
customize your content for each event i
cannot tell you
how many times
i see speakers
and orators and teachers and whoever
and they have a really great message
but with each new audience they go to
ninety percent of the message is the
same i gotta be honest with you some of
the people that i know in the industry
some of my friends they do it and i love
them and i love their heart but i truly
believe that the audience is paying for
the lack of energy let me just say lazy
the audience is paying because you're
being lazy
customized
your message for your audience who are
they how are they different and even if
it's the same demographic so they're
still women and they're still
entrepreneurs but are we in a different
time i dare not deliver the exact same
message this year to the same
demographic that i delivered in 2019.
why
too much has happened
she he they are in a totally new place
so you want to make sure that your
message
addresses your audience now let me just
tell you something i saw a very powerful
speaker i will not mention his name
i saw a very powerful speaker
be so sure that he can move the audience
that when he was speaking to his
audience he actually went in a direction
that this audience wasn't interested in
but it's where his speech was
and it was a great speech
great speech
for another audience
and he was on autopilot
so i want you to think about it this way
you don't talk to everyone in your life
the same way you know if you were
talking to a three-year-old you have a
three-year-old's conversation if you
were talking to a 15-year-old
you have a 15-year-old's conversation to
relate to them and if you were talking
to a 55-year-old
or let's just look at me because that's
where i happen to be right now in my
life you would speak to me differently
and so you don't speak
to your partner the way you speak to
your boss the way you speak to your
children the way you speak to your
friend you talk to them in a way that
fits the relationship that you're in
with them your audience is the exact
same way
taking the time to customize your
message you can be talking about the
same content
same content same technique i teach
about speaking all the time but i'm
always saying am i talking to a
corporate employee am i talking to a
corporate exec am i talking to an
entrepreneur am i speaking to a teenager
same content
but i apply the message
so that it fits the audience this allows
the audience to feel as if you've
customized something for them and they
have a more intimate connection to you
rule number three design your powerful
clothes
step three is about designing your
powerful clothes so most people end with
a fizzle
and i'm gonna say the one of the major
foundation to a powerful message is to
end with fire
like fire
so end with fire not a fizzle speakers
often overlook and dismiss the clothes
because they're so committed to the
content and they think oh it's the end
no
like think about it when you're at a
concert when you're at a concert and
like you're with like a mega artist like
a mega artist like if it were prince or
tina turner or
janet jackson or beyonce or mayor j
blige or if you're with kenny g or
you're like you're just you have
a a concert a major concert
they don't end with the fizzle they
don't end with the
the song that no one knew that didn't go
gold or didn't hit a major status or
that you you can't sing along with
they crescendo
and they may go down and give you some
of the you know ones that are more
mediocre in the middle but at the end
they come out and do the encore even and
the encore is always something that gets
everyone to sing along it's encore that
just it's fire
that's exactly how your message needs to
be
so
let me let you in on the secret sauce
like a lot of things that i love to do
now is really taking you behind the
black curtain on powerful speeches
behind the black curtain on becoming
unforgettable when you open your mouth
or when you present in front of people
your clothes here here it is you ready
for it you ready for it
your clothes
is so important
it's the audience's last impression of
you and most people go
height height height height height and
down and bye
i've me i've witnessed so many times
great speeches
speeches that kept me engaged
and kept me excited
until the end
every time this happens
i'm screaming inside my head no
no no no no no please
don't let don't make your last
impression of fizzle rule number four
connect with your audience this is about
step four this one is huge for
connecting with your audience and
keeping them interested and engaged now
so many times i see speakers are
presenters speaking and they're not
checking in with their audience to even
see if they're listening anymore and as
a result people are on their phones or
they're doing whatever they're
multitasking
you want to keep your audience
absolutely engaged
so let me give you some techniques you
want to identify your audience's drivers
you want to know these things before you
even open your mouth like you want to
know what makes your audience tick
what gets them excited
what gets them into action what's super
important to them what's the w-i-i-f-m
what's in it for me but in this case
what's in it for them what drives them
what motivates them this step is beyond
customizing your speech which is what i
mentioned in a previous show this is
really understanding the psychographic
of your audience whether you're on
social media that's an audience whether
you're teaching a class that's an
audience whether you're talking to one
individual that's an audience so you
have to ask yourself
what's the red button for this
particular group of individuals
when i speak to mothers
i recognize that a mother's job is to
make her children feel safe her mother's
job is to make them feel loved a mother
also feels overwhelmed she's also the
multi-tasker of all times she also needs
rest and
she wants to be acknowledged many times
she's under acknowledged i know that i
know that before i start talking to the
moms or even when i'm talking to an
audience and i say if you are a mother
then and i go i begin to go into the
things that i know is important to a
mother if i'm speaking to a group of
speakers
or entrepreneurs then i know it's about
several things it's about impact you
want your voice to be heard
you also want to know that your voice is
powerful you want to know that your
message is being received you also want
to monetize your message so it's not
just about speaking it's also about the
business
if i'm speaking to teens during our
motivating the teen spirit events then
as a teen i go okay so teens are not
making a lot of decisions in their lives
for themselves decisions are being made
around they want to own their voice they
want to hear their own voice they're
tired of rules so in the motivating the
team spirit when i'm talking to teens i
say here are no rules
they go what
in this space we just make agreements
together
man they perk up as soon as i do that
because they're not used to that so to
that point you want to make sure that
you understand what the needs and the
desires and what motivates the audience
that you're speaking to before you even
open your mouth you don't want to just
speak to what's important to you you
want to speak to what's important to
them and what are those hot buttons what
are those red buttons that will make
them go look
look
let me listen a little closer
this part of the process may sound like
a lot of work but it's worth it because
it can turn a speech a message into an
experience
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five create a symphony
of energy step number five
you want to take the techniques
the previous four techniques that i've
given you and if you're in any one of my
courses it's actually 17 techniques
and you want to make it sound like a
symphony and and the reason why this is
a step is because most people look at
techniques and look at things they do
very fragmented well i'm gonna say and i
like to call it two things one make it
sound like a symphony meaning you want
your message to blend together think of
it as if you were writing a song
because a message should be rhythmic it
should be like a song it should have
this cadence to it it should have this
alliteration to it it should have this
flow to it it has this opening it has
this middle this arc and it has this
ending and it all comes together right
that's the symphony that's the sound
that's the band
the other way you can look at it is
you want to take your individual
ingredients
and then you want to layer them together
like lasagna
and you want to put them on lasagna is
actually not one of the easiest dishes
to make because it's about individual
mastery of the particular taste and the
particular seasonings and then it's also
about layering it in such a way that it
meshes together and comes out in one
form that's how a great message is you
take the techniques audience connection
you take the techniques um ending with a
fire not a fizzle you take the
techniques uh understanding what's in it
for your audience you take the
techniques verbal highlights and you do
all these techniques and then you go how
do i layer them content and story and
opening and close yeah again i say this
ain't elementary this is mba
right so it takes a minute but if you've
implemented the first four steps
then you have delicious content
you understand what a soul stirring
story looks like because i taught you
the valley
you understand the crescendo and the
clothes
now
it's time for you as the conductor or
like my son jaylani as the head chef
as he is a a chef of all times
now you want to put the dish together or
as the conductor you want to create a
beautiful symphony of words
yeah i know when you think of it that
way it's like well lisa it's just a
message no it's not
it's life for someone who's listening
it's life for someone who needs your
words so take the time and create a
symphony of oration create a symphony of
possibility create a symphony of energy
because when you speak
and you speak possibility you speak
education you speak motivation you're
speaking life rule number six tell
powerful stories you need to have
content
and you need to have stories
now the number of stories that you offer
in your message has a lot to do with how
much time you have because you always
want to give your audience of one or of
many online virtual or live you want to
give them enough content to walk away
with value however
it's super important that you give them
enough story
to walk away with a connection so what
normally happens
some of the best speakers that are
out there today best presenters
they are only doing one or the other
they fall flat in one of those areas
they're either all story and you don't
have enough content to write down or
they're all content that's pretty much
the majority of people they're all
content
and there's
very few opportunities to make a
connection so why do you deliver content
you deliver content because it's the
intellectual learning that you're going
to teach your audience right whether
it's new concepts it's the theory that
provides your audience with the insight
to move forward content is the steps the
how-to content is where they choose to
follow you as an expert
as a coach
as a leader because you have insight on
neuro-linguistic programming behavior
management media
marketing you you got that content on
personal perseverance and transformation
you are the content provider for that
particular body of work meaning your
intellectual property will help move
them forward in their life in that area
super super important now that i want
you to put that by itself
that's important the mistake most
speakers make most presenters make is
that they give you all of that
well i walk away with value
but you miss a huge part of me
now where is that
that's from the story so the story
is that experience that you share
that grounds the content
and makes it real
now you don't have to necessarily point
to the content you're just sharing a
story about a time in your life and that
story just gives context it gives 3d it
gives texture what i like to call it to
what you're talking about to the content
it brings the content to life in a
moment let me give an example
well the story is what allows the
audience
to see themselves in you
the story is what creates the
the
the vibration the energy exchange
remember content doesn't create an
energy exchange
content creates an intellectual exchange
you want an energy exchange why
content will have people respect you
stories will have people become loyal to
you rule number seven ask questions you
may ask
how do you customize
how do you customize lisa a message for
your audience how do you know what the
audience needs that's what i would be
asking me right now how do i know what
the audience needs ask questions
write this down
your listeners or your customers
are the experts
say that my customers are the experts my
students are the experts
the next line
i am the service provider
oh when i got that years ago that my
customers my audience my students you
you're the expert
you're the expert of your journey
because you know what you need more than
i do
you're the expert on what you need i'm
the service provider
so the best thing you can do is ask
questions what matters to you most these
days what problem are you working to
solve what's keeping you up at night
what would you where what era would you
love to grow in what's your pain point
what are the 10 things that you're
tolerating right now they're not
screaming loud enough to make you change
them but they're screaming loud enough
to annoy you
i ask those questions
collect the data put it in your back
pocket and as you're creating content
and as you're creating programs create
programs and content that speaks to what
your audience has already shared with
you rule number eight build your
credibility i'm going to tell you there
are many other techniques i have to
teach you in the science of speaking
that would help you
this is one of those cornerstones
so as i was saying
the top of the v
right is the big you so it's where you
build your credibility
no shrinking here
if you're really really humble and you
really reserve this is sort of where it
will become challenging for you some
people they really can go in their
valley easy right most of us for some
it's difficult
for others it's difficult to actually
share the big you your credibility
this is where you share your highlights
this is where you share your experiences
your accolades your achievements your
credentials and it can't seem like it's
a bio
like or a resume so i graduated from and
i know it's you say because you're going
to take them into the valley
so you want to say even though you want
to kind of give a little clue that
you're about to take them somewhere else
even though
i have seven best sellers
and i've spoken and inspired over 86
million people
and i've been able to travel and be on
every single continent that could be
populated by man
even though
i've generated over 80 million dollars
in business in in the self training and
self development industry in my company
over the last 27 years
even though
that's who i am
you see how i just
gave you the credentials inside of a
even though or you can say what you may
or may not know about me
what you may or may not know about me is
that i'm a best-selling author times
seven books
what you may or may not know about me is
that i have
been featured on every uh major national
platform
what you may or may not know about me
is
i have lost
over a million dollars and i've earned
over 88 million
but what i'm sure you don't know about
me is
notice how the big u you you say it in
such a way where it leads into the
valley so it's not a bio it's not spoken
as if it's a bio it's not spoken as if
it is a
um
if it is a um
resume it's spoken as if it's a
conversation that's about to lead into
the valley all of that that i just share
with you and i just use my
my experience my life as an example to
give you
you do yours and don't compare yours to
mine right comparison as benjamin
franklin says comparison is and will
always be the thief of all your joy rule
number nine leave your audience wanting
more you want to leave them
wanting more the number one tip for a
powerful clothes is to leave them
wanting more now mind you hold on hold
on i want to make sure you understand
you leave them wanting more
having already given them something so
please don't be one of those bait and
switch speakers
that drives me crazy
like don't tell me if you come to my
thing i'ma really tell you how and the
whole speech you're delivering how
you're going to help them in that next
experience
don't be a bait and switch speaker don't
be a bait and switch teacher give me
value now
and then
tell me where i can get more from you
leave me wanting more from you all right
and the way you can do this write this
down
here are some of my favorite
um it's called the one the disappearing
clothes you have the audience talk oh
this one right like wait hold on you
gotta know now
now this isn't a beginner's move
this is
like a gladiator move you've been in it
for a while you've been doing messages
for a while um this is if your audience
is either physically together
right or
you can online you can open up their
lines and have them talk or you can have
them begin to type in chat right
and i call this first one because we'll
get back together live life is going to
continue we'll get back together live
we'll never be like we were but we will
be evolved from this
time
and when you're live in front of an
audience
or it's a small group
it's what i call the disappearing close
and the disappearing clothes is so bold
because it says i've given you so much
value i've contributed so much i've i've
left my fingerprint on you that i don't
need to be a part of the closing
experience i'm gonna do a disappearing
close which means you turn the audience
to one another
this is what it looks like i want you to
turn and find at least three people in
the room go up to them and say i'm ready
for the next best version of me are you
i'm ready for the next best version of
me are you ready find three people and
say that to them another disappearing
clothes is i want you to go find a
partner right now everyone go find a
partner raise your hand if you need to
have a partner everyone great everyone
has a partner i want you to tell that
partner what are three things that they
can expect from you what are three
things that they
and and let them represent the world you
can expect me to honor my word you can
expect me to live inside my time
management you can expect me to change
the planet
tell that same neighbor
i'm interested in what you're doing what
are you doing what's the world going to
expect from you so you can create a
one-on-one or you can create a walk
around and say you can do i just pick
those sentences just right now in the
moment but you can have them talk to one
person
or you can have them walk around the
room you also can guide the conversation
turn to your partner repeat after me i
stand in front of you and they'll say i
stand in front of you ready to
become the best version of myself ready
to become the best verse you can have
them talk to each other and create a
solid connection super powerful that's
the disappearing clothes the other
clothes is you can close with a poem it
doesn't have to be your poem
you can close with the quote
oh it's really powerful when you close
with a quote that like is just juicy and
delicious or you can close with a
statement that another person says that
drops everyone in their heart i used to
always close with my grandmother says
that when you get to the end of your
life and you're at the end of your
journey and you're in your later years
that you're supposed to sit in your
favorite rocking chair and share with
everyone who will listen the stories of
your life which is what my grandma does
right now
she says but baby when you're your age
and i would point to the audience when
you're your age you're supposed to make
sure that that story that you're going
to share is going to be real good to
tell
go out
and make a great story i would always
end with that
i can people would always say oh man i
love that when you said i'm gonna make
my great story
or i would end with remember you guys
no one can do you like you can do you
benjamin franklin says comparison is and
will always be the thief of all your joy
don't compare just compliment compliment
us with who you are go do you so you can
find a quote and you can end with a
quote or you could end with a call to
action
and so i challenge each one of you i
challenge you to play big i challenge
you to speak up stand up show up stay
prayed up
i challenge you to step up in a way
you've never stepped up before and as
you do i'll be cheering you on so you
can end with a challenge like that
you also can end in a question um i
if i end in a question it's like a
rhetorical question it's like a bunch of
what-ifs so as i leave i leave you with
this
what if
what if you showed up like you've never
showed up before what if you dance as if
no one was looking what if you love as
if your heart's never been broken what
if you sing as if you're always on key
what if you shine as if we all can
handle your shine i just got that
question for you as i leave
what if
what if you gave us the best version of
you
what if
the importance of a powerful close i
cannot tell you enough how it makes all
the difference in the world
like when you're anchoring your message
your clothes is a critical component so
remember don't fizzle me
leave me on fire and rule number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is make an impact why do we want
to create a powerful message because
every time you open your mouth you want
to create impact
every time whether you're talking to
your friends
your children your family members
whether you're talking to an audience of
one or an audience of one hundred or one
thousand or a hundred thousand whether
you're in a board room or whether you're
walking on the beach you wanna create
impact
now if you're a business owner or an
entrepreneur then this message is super
important for you because it has
everything to do with you attracting
your ideal customer and keeping them
so i won't say that this is the final
step
because
i created an outline for the science of
impactful speaking culminating my 27
years at the time that i shot this video
27 years in the business and creating a
multi-million dollar platform and i got
to tell you the first part the first 10
12 years of me creating this
crazy successful
global business and brand i didn't even
know
the techniques i was doing it was my
unconscious competence
and over a period of time i thought whoa
i keep creating this tsunami of new
clients tsunami of new business partners
what's happening and i began to look at
and and study what were the techniques
that i did on stage on camera
in interviews that kept creating this
tremendous
wave of success
and then i began to shape it so that i
can create techniques out of it so it
wasn't it wouldn't just be my superpower
but it can become your superpower as
well
what happens when you feel like you're
always being judged
number one
is divorce yourself from trying to
manage someone's judgment of you i know
that sounds backwards because we want to
go over there and change them i know
well when i figure that one out you'll
be the first to know but in the meantime
how can you
separate yourself divorce i know it's a
strong word but that's the separation
from the need
to monitor other people's judgment of
you
let me tell you what that answer is you
go over to self-awareness you go over to
recognizing i am whole
i am smart enough i am wise enough i am
kind enough not from a bragging way not
from a self-righteous way from the most
humble way possible
can you wake up tomorrow morning
and be content with who you are
irregardless of anyone's opinion of you
once you leave the house or maybe the
person next to you or the people
downstairs the people in your same house
can you wake up tomorrow
standing and living in the statement and
the knowing i am enough
and then
leave everyone's opinion to them you
know procrastination is really putting
off your own desires procrastination is
putting yourself last procrastination
shows up when we are so used to putting
everyone else in front of us or
we're actually afraid to do that thing
that we say we want to do because we're
not sure if we can handle the outcome
but the whole attachment to
procrastination and self-love
what you can do tomorrow why not do
today
what you can do today why not do right
now
you know one of my team members talked
about reading a book called touch it
once
which means if you can touch it once and
get it done how much more productive
will you be unconsciously we have a
tendency
to do things to influence someone's
perception of us
and really what we're trying to do is
change our control ah that word again
we're trying to control their perception
of us because we feel like they're being
judged so we get into the proving
business i said in another lisa nichols
episode that you have nothing to prove
nothing to protect nothing to hide and
nothing to defend that's not just a
mouthful of words that is literally a
lifetime of disconnecting from the need
to prove to someone you're smart enough
you're kind enough you're loving enough
you're worthy enough you're enough dot
dot dot right
and i remember for years because i
didn't graduate from college i was
always trying to prove i was smart
enough
always
and then i had a son without being
married so then i wanted to prove that i
was godly enough i was always trying to
prove something until it just became so
exhausting
what i was doing was trying to control
people's judgment of me i'll try says
i'll make a feeble attempt i will is
absolute non-negotiable no matter what
there's a certain energy that goes forth
when you say i'll try and there's a
different energy that goes forth when
you say i will when you make the
declaration of i will that says mountain
if you are there
you must move
i'll try says i hope i got enough energy
to make it up or around the mountain and
if not i'm gonna sit at the bottom of
the hill
when you fail to make a plan okay well
hold on this might hit you between the
eyes you know i love you but when you
fail to make a clear concrete plan that
has goals and milestones meaning they're
smaller goals that you can hit to get to
the bigger goal and has a by win date
not in february not in august but august
15th
by 5 pm
eastern standard time yeah when i set a
goal i even want to know the time zone
and have it done by clarity when you
fail to make a plan with clear
distinction when you fail to make a
clear plan
you have clearly planned to fail
i'll say it again
when you fail to make a clear plan
then you've clearly planned to fail i
know that hits you hard i've done it
many times i have clearly planned to
fail many times because i had an idea
and it was just in my unconscious i
didn't know now i want to bring to you
what i know to you so you know it i want
you to make a clear plan when you create
a clear plan then you're clearly
planning to succeed acknowledge your
community
see when you celebrate the people around
you that bring you joy or that teach you
some of the hardest lessons that you
need to learn
the iron that sharpens the iron
the celebrators that celebrate you those
who hold the space for you and with you
pray for you
honor you
when you celebrate and lift them up the
whole tide rises
so i want you to find six people in your
community
not out of obligation but truly out of
choice
they can be in your circle in your
family in your business circle and i
want you to acknowledge them
for the contribution that they bring to
your life
what i love about acknowledgement is
that when you acknowledge other people
it actually makes you happier
it's just this amazing gift of giving
and what i love is that most people
would rather get an acknowledgement from
you than a physical gift
that means they don't necessarily need
the perfume they don't need the sweater
they don't need the
new iphone whatever they want you to
look at them in their eyes and say you
bring value you bring value to my life
i honor you i celebrate you i appreciate
you
take time to have a personal moment with
them where you're just
seeing them
the number one reason why people feel
sad and disconnected is because they say
they don't feel seen
so in this acknowledgement i want you to
look into their eyes
and acknowledge them for who they are
and how they make your life
better when you raise the community
around you the entire tide rises the
energy rises the joy rises the
expectation rises and guess what if you
make this a part of your weekly habits
with them i didn't say daily i didn't
say monthly either and i definitely
didn't say annually but if you make this
a part of your weekly find one thing to
acknowledge at least six people in your
community for each week one you'll feel
like
you'll feel much more excited but all of
a sudden there's a vibration
that happens because you've created it
there's this energy of let's go do this
because what gets celebrated gets
repeated you want someone to repeatedly
do something wonderful and amazing in
your life you repeatedly acknowledge
them from a genuine place
man it's so powerful when you truly
marry yourself to the acknowledgement
process to the practice of
acknowledgement when you get into the
practice of acknowledgement all of a
sudden people will mirror back to you
you don't acknowledge to get it back you
acknowledge because you want people to
be seen but there's just this this dance
that begins to occur that's absolutely
delicious your belief systems were
handed to you by your parents and by
your grandparents and they were pretty
much embedded by the time you were 10
years old so there's some beliefs that
you didn't even have a chance to develop
for your own you just are living them
out you inherited them you inherit the
beliefs
and didn't unconsciously inherited them
and so the good news is you get to
choose to the belief systems you like
and then you get to divorce i'm gonna
say divorce because that's a strong word
we all know what separation looks like
when you say divorce you get to divorce
from a belief system that doesn't serve
you any longer a belief system that says
money is the root of all evil maybe or a
belief system that says only rich people
uh have money or all rich people are are
are uh crooks or
i you said my belief system used to be
that wealthy people aren't spiritual
that if i'm wealthy i can't be a
spiritual person you have to pick god or
money one or the other i gotta pick my
faith or my finances i can't have both
that's a belief system and and i invite
you to divorce it because it's not the
case i have both and i live in both
quite well i use my money for good in
the world and the more the more money
you have the more good you'll do if
you're a good person so money makes you
more of who you are so you will only be
more of who you are with money every
relationship is a relay
it's like my dad's played tennis for
over 40 years and and i've attempted to
play with him at times and what i
realized is that relationships are like
a tennis match i hit the ball to you
you hit the ball back
and a relationship where you think it's
only about one person that's not tennis
that's racquetball
right but a relationship is a tennis
match and so if a relationship is
working it's because of the way we both
are engaging
if it's truly working and if it's not
working
it's the way we both are engaging and so
there could be passive engagement
and there could be active engagement so
when you're not speaking up for what you
want when you're holding and you're
living with a bunch of withholds that's
engagement that's just the way you're
engaging so
so every relationship has two parts
whether your part is active or your part
is passive every relationship has
engagement a level of engagement and
that engagement is on different levels
oh my god i love this question
i don't think i've ever been asked this
question before i never had an
opportunity to explain it
being the best version of you first of
all it's not don't think of it holistic
i want you to break it down to different
parts of your life because when you are
committed to being the best version of
you which in summary it's the you that
you're so incredibly proud of
holistically it's a 360 approach it says
i'm not perfect
so best
does not mean the perfect version of you
because i think perfection and balance
are two illusions that are designed to
help you keep chasing something that's
not even attainable so perfect is not
attainable and balance is not attainable
so it's perfectly managing my
imperfection
and releasing balance and having harmony
number one
but the best version of you is really
saying that in each area of my life i'm
in movement in each area of my life i'm
an evolution in each area of my life i'm
active i am actively participating in an
upwardly way in an upperly mobile way in
this area of my life times
every area of my life it doesn't
necessarily mean that you're always
where you want to be but it does mean
that you're being responsible you're
being active and you're being proactive
finances that you're looking at your
numbers just this morning
just this morning i ran my credit score
again i want to see what's on it i want
to be actively participating in my
financial growth i looked at my savings
i looked at my life insurance i just
looked at my my long-term plan
not necessarily because i want to buy
another house or i want to buy a car i
just want to be on top of it i want to
be responsible for it and then health
and wellness just yesterday i was
talking to matt and going matt it's time
for us to do another health and wellness
campaign i don't necessarily want to do
it and it slightly to moderately scares
me a bit when i'm bringing my fitness
into a public conversation but i know
the responsible me the best version of
lisa is saying hold me accountable hold
me accountable to my fitness goals hold
me accountable to my total wellness
goals
and then last week i was just sitting
with someone saying you know what i need
to go down the list of all the checkups
that i've had i need to make sure i'm
not missing anything
relationships i just said to a
girlfriend yesterday hold me accountable
hold me accountable to not running
i realize that i run well and i run
smoothly i run like a gazelle sometimes
when it comes to relationships you know
it doesn't even look like i'm running
because i'm so busy
so i ask someone who knows me who knows
the love that i want who knows my sexy
excuses
i need you to hold me accountable when i
say this i want you to question it and
so while there's so much growth in every
area of my life
i'm being the best version that i know
to be because i'm active in every single
area i'm not saying i'm being the best i
am the best please don't get me wrong
with that i'm just saying to be the best
version of myself so when you look at
being the best version of yourself look
at each part of your life
and go what am i actively doing where
you feel like i'm in the game in this
area i'm not resigned and i'm not
praying for it to go right or i'm not in
resignation and then complaint about it
i'm not a victim to that relationship
i'm not a victim to my finances i'm not
a victim to the relationships in my
family i'm an active part of creating
what's occurring
and it can always get better but i'm an
active part that's
being the best version of you and waking
up each morning and saying i like me
today
i got many things i can work on
but i like me today before you ever go
out on facebook or any other social
media platform to check to see if anyone
else like you
your job is to like you first and every
other like is bonus that's stepping into
the best version of you setting
long-term goals that make your knees
knock a little bit and make your teeth
chatter a little bit those goals that
you don't know exactly how you gonna get
it done
but it's something that you want to get
done it doesn't it stretches you but it
doesn't stress you your goals are
supposed to stretch you
not stress you
those things that combination and when
you live in that capacity and you focus
and you operate in that one
that's when you're living in being the
best
version of you did you consciously sit
down and say i want to manifest
inspiring millions of people making
millions of dollars was it was it a
conscious thing were there moments where
you sat there when you weren't living in
that reality where you said you know
what i'm going to decide i'm going to
figure it out i might not know how i
don't know where or what but i'm going
to commit to it and make it a reality i
mean talk to me at the core of your
experience right so i love how you say
millions of dollars i said i want to
inspire people and i wouldn't want to be
able to pay my bills
that was initially
i want to i want to have a i want to run
out of month
before i run out of money
big
i want to have enough
that like you can't think about having
abundance until you you literally give
yourself permission to have enough yeah
i get past scarcity today like so i want
to have enough to dream and so
my first i have i think i have a
ministry mindset my first i just want to
help people i want to help people who
and i want to i want to be rewarded for
my efforts right and then once i got
past that i said okay
i want more
i want to generate millions i want to
serve millions inspire millions and
generate millions i i think i deserve
all of that but that had to do with my
self-worth right i had to feel worthy
to touch millions
and i had to feel worthy to touch
millions
i had to feel worthy of both
and so that was personal development
which is why i live and i stay in
personal development i teach personal
development i teach wealth development i
teach business development and i teach
personal development because you have to
have both setting quarterly goals to
recognize that goals that are going to
be hit are goals that are bite-sized
digestible and palatable and you can
measure them every 90 days we together
discovered that 90-day goals allows us
to get to annual goals and two-year
goals and five-year goals but 90-day
goals allows you to have bite-sized
palatable digestible goals that could be
measured and or adjusted every 90 days
i'm only telling you the lesson that i
had to learn that we train people how to
treat us in 2007 when i was on the oprah
show it was the thing that came up and
out of me and she was like yes it was
that thing that said we train people how
to treat us
like they're looking at how we're what
we're saying yes to and what we're
co-signing on and if we're the yes woman
or the yes man all the time then one our
yes isn't as valuable because everyone
automatically expects it because we give
it away all the time and two they're
gonna keep asking because they know
we're gonna get that they're gonna get
yes
and if you're a producer and deliverer
you're the one i'm gonna come to all the
time because you're producer and
delivery you're gonna get the job done
even to the detriment of your own joy
even to the detriment of your own
happiness but again
you train people how to treat you
but the good news
about training someone
is that they can be retrained if you
find that the relationships around you
have toxic outcomes then i want you to
look at where is the breakdown is the
breakdown in communication is the
breakdown in how you communicate the
words you're using
is the breakdown in who you choose to be
around
it's the breakdown in the engagement of
what you're talking about what i've
learned is that if you're not talking
about things that are high enough and
big enough
things that are inspiring enough you
will slip into the smallness
every single time if you don't choose an
intentionally high evolving encouraging
conversation you will slip into the
cracks you will slip into those crevices
of smallness and petty and until you get
people trained that you're going to live
up here without telling them i need you
to know it's not an announcement it's a
way of being and so what do you choose
to participate in it's a stepping over
your desire to hear smallness
gossip
negative feedback it's when someone is
engaging in negative feedback about
someone else the fact that you didn't
add anything to the conversation doesn't
let you off the hook
did you stop the conversation
did you say hold on i don't want to
engage in speaking negatively of them at
all why don't you have a conversation
with them it's course correcting
behaviors in your space at the risk
at the risk of losing the relationship
but what you basically do is is you say
here's where i play
here is where i live i'm not visiting
this high road of integrity i'm not
visiting this high road of conscious
thinking and awareness and respect and
humility and and honoring the dignity
and people i don't visit this place
i live here
i don't visit this place
and in a loving way anyone that's
engaging with you has two choices
they either engage with you here
or they choose to engage with someone
else
now if you find
that you're going down
to be in the relationship or you're
going down and you're taking and you're
the person taking the relationship down
because you're in a moment of anger or
you're in a moment of resentment or
you're in a moment of hurt then you're
not living in your highest integrity you
just visit every now and again when you
come to this channel
uh-oh i see my my
my shantae coming out right now shantae
is my middle name it's what i do when i
start getting real edgy because i really
want you to get it
so you need to make a decision on where
you choose to reside
and then you don't leave your conscious
neighborhood
to go visit other people's neighborhood
if it's not as high as yours
people will rise to the occasion or
they'll choose not to rise and they'll
pick other people to be with and hang
with and i know that sounds easier said
than done because some of the people who
are playing at a lower level might be in
family it might be and that's fine too
you can love people it doesn't mean you
have to spend tons and tons and tons of
time if that time costs you something
spend as much time as you can
spend as much time as serves you spend
as much time as they will allow you to
spend but never leave this place
even if being with them causes you to to
allow them to be where they are you
don't have to engage in that so the
bottom line
and
supporting you to either recognize are
you the toxic element are you
surrounding yourself in toxic element is
to make a commitment where you live
where am i living and first own where
you're currently living because if you
own it you might go you know what i do
slip into that small place okay own it
that's conscious awareness
that's powerful
own it and then go where do i want to be
and then what's the distance between
here and there and what do i have to do
to get there
what i have to say no to do i have to
participate in what i have to ask
forgiveness for what i have to clean up
what relationships require cleaning up
and then what declarations must i make
and what decisions must i live in don't
make a decision
living your decision practice active yes
i'm gonna say it again underlined circle
active practice active self-care that's
where you identified what rejuvenates
you and made plans to make time for
self-care during the busy season so you
made a list of what you know
rejuvenates your soul your mind your
body your spirit from walking on the
beach to reading a book to taking down
time free things and retreats or a spa
whatever it is that rejuvenates your
soul to make a list of it and then to
make plans
active self-care to do those things
during your busy season to the
conversation about money and wealth um
it's one
being willing to release a familiar now
for an unfamiliar future now that's
that's easier said than done and it's
bigger than it sounds
are you willing
to have your future look unfamiliar and
in some cases
look around
and you don't recognize anything
are you willing are you so tied to the
comfort of what you know even in this
discomfort
so i was willing to reinvent myself
a thousand times are you willing to
reinvent yourself are you willing to
introduce yourself to the new version of
you yes are you willing to go places you
wouldn't go and do things that you
traditionally wouldn't do see i wasn't
traditionally in meditation or in
visualization or hanging around older
white men or like i had a thousand
things
that i didn't do traditionally when we
talk about living our quest
um
i think that living my quest really if i
look at on a daily basis it's
finding my own voice
it's finding your voice it's finding the
song that only you can sing
off-key or not
it's finding your rhythm
it's discovering what it feels like to
walk
in your shoes
today
it won't look like it looked ten years
ago
living your quest
is
what can i do with my life
so that my life becomes infectious to
someone else
living my quest looks like how do i make
my fingerprint
matter so big that it lives beyond my
transition day
living your quest
is how can i forgive
the perceivingly unforgivable so i can
love the absolute lovable
living your quest
is how do i
give myself a thousand second chances
and every time i get to 9.99
press reset
yeah
living my quest is is not some ambiguous
untouchable experience
living my quest
means going back and healing the little
girl in me
so that the woman can be free
it's going back and embracing the little
boy in you so that the man can show up
and give himself permission to cry when
necessary
living your quest is not something that
you can't touch it's not something that
requires a stage or lights or cameras
living your quest is being completely
content with who you are in the dark of
the night
so who you are in the middle of the day
is all right
living your quest is as simple as it is
complex
living your quest is about giving
yourself permission say permission
on a daily basis to become the next best
version of yourself
living your quest is not holding
yourself hostage to old decisions
not holding yourself hostage to shame
blame guilt regret and anger living your
quest is about recognizing that every
day i can be reborn to my possibility
see it's very difficult to speak
phenomenally and to not be good come on
y'all from yesterday not be great but to
be what
[Applause]
unfreaking forgettable
it's difficult to be unforgettable while
you're still trying to look good
you can't do two things as chasing two
rabbits see unforgettable has everything
to do with serving at a level so high so
big so massive that people feel like
they have to change their lives because
they crossed your path
yes yes
see
see when you're willing
to use your voice first you have to
recognize that you have
one you got to recognize that that no
matter your past you were given a voice
and the your voice was given not to keep
to yourself your voice is not a secret
says the secret teacher
and you have to be willing to use every
experience that's ever happened in your
life not as a fortress holding you from
using your voice but as the fuel on why
you will use your voice
you got to be willing to not stand in
your story but stand on your story
yes
yes it's not in spite of your past that
you get to be amazing that you get to be
a change agent that you get to transform
lives it's because of your past that
you're perfect for such a job
when you own it like that see there's no
question in my certainty about my life
can you walk with that level of
certainty so that when the wind comes
and then when the wind blows and it will
come and it will blow and it will be a
storm and it will be a tornado and it
will look like divorce and it will look
like bankruptcy and it will look like an
illness and it will look like a loss
when it comes it will rock you it will
rock you it will rock you but it won't
move you the oprah team had heard some
of my backstory
and they said can we send a camera crew
much like this wonderful camera crew yes
not nearly as good-looking
and can we send a camera crew to capture
your story
and so i share my story and i mean i
dumped
and dumped
and i shared the ugly
and right after the interview i
regretted it
because i i didn't think i could be the
secret teacher
the expert and have that kind of ugly
out there in the world i didn't know i
didn't know that the world would love me
for what i've come through i thought
that they would they would consider me
an imposter in the secret
and so i shared all this junk
two weeks later i'm on my way to oprah
to do the actual recording and i know
what i requ i know the video
so the night before i'm packing and i'm
crying oh my god
it's over tomorrow
it's all over i'm gonna embarrass myself
it's the fastest career up and down
anyone's ever seen lisa nichols will be
the secret yes right so
um
so i i'm just sad i'm scared and i and i
call a friend of mine at 4 15 in the
morning because i stayed up all night of
course yeah how are you going to sleep
yeah you're right right and i said my
god and then they don't know my junk in
the video and um it's over and he said
can i pray for you lisa
and i was like sure
my friend says
god
thank you for using your imperfect child
to help your imperfect children
i went to oprah the next day
and as the chatter kept going in my head
leading up to the moment when they play
this video
i'm like it's okay
i'm enough
i'm enough with all my mess i'm enough
i'm enough and the chatter kept nope
they're gonna find out they're gonna
find out your son's father is in jail
they're gonna find out that they're
gonna fight and i thought no they're not
gonna find out because i'm gonna tell
them
because there's power and transparency
there's power and authenticity there's
power and truth that i'm going to speak
life into someone else because they're
going to see who i am
because of that in spite of that with
that
and so then the after show came so after
the regular oprah show the after show
and man i cracked open on the after show
and within 72 hours
talk about the power of transparency and
authenticity within 72 hours i received
8782 emails
and my email wasn't even lisa nichols it
wasn't even easy to find and my website
wasn't lisa nichols yeah
they people searching for me whatever it
took because of the truth and so i have
the imposter syndrome then
i've had it since then
people told me oh my god you're the
answer and i'm searching for my own
answers
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there